all right uh welcome back everyone um to
our last talk today we have uh
talked about using observations
experimental data for uh medical
decision making
um
again please during your talk just uh
clarifying questions
and uh yeah then after that we'll have a
panel discussion where we can have a
more kind of
take on the more bigger picture
questions all right yeah with that jamie
please uh take us away
okay um
thanks for having me and um i'm going to
talk about
using observational experimental data
for medical decision making
um
so most of this talk is just going to be
um
opinions and concerns and um there's
a good um puzzle
at one place and some interesting
technical stuff at the end
or semi-technical okay so the big issue
is
so
i've been doing for years trying to
develop methods to get um estimate
causal effects in
medical settings from observational
data and from randomized trials
especially when something's gone wrong
like non-compliance
so the question everyone asks in
medicine is how do we know we are right
when we say there's an effect that there
isn't an effect based on these analyses
and there's now something called the
causal lab orbit school of public health
this was there was a initiated symposium
in november 2021 on this topic
and uh so we want to determine how
successful we're being and how do we
adjust our methods become
uh more so and this is uh
an aspirational talk the sense of what
if we did not have re resource
constraints in terms of money and most
importantly trained causal now experts
with substantive scientific knowledge
and judgment that is we could have what
we wanted
um how do we tell what work what works
when and where the when and where refer
to the fact that we are always asking in
the context of a particular causal
question observational database
all of which are constrained by sample
size rigorous comprehensive data
collection
substantive issues um
whether there's a lot of confounding by
indication confounding by indication is
when the doctor doctor gives you the
drug because you're doing badly so those
who badly get treated more
severely severe confounding and is the
effect of treatment or adverse exposure
likely small
on a
um
i meant
likely large on a risk ratio scale but
still important
on a medical or public health
perspective like common diseases like
coronary heart disease it's hard to
detect small um
uh
relative
you can have a small relative wrist
that's hard to detect that
the relative risk
yeah i said around the relative risk can
be small let's say 1.2
the risk ratio but that could have a
huge public um health effect i would say
um
if it's a common disease
okay and so forth um our longitudinal
measurements frequent measurement or
control so
so forth and a lot of these studies are
done with
electronic uh health records um and so
that this is all tied in with how should
someone improve electronic health
records but i'm not going to talk about
that i'm just talking about what you do
in the face of current restraint
constraints through the nature of those
records
so even the best causal methods don't
really deliverable conclusions
um when it filed to lousy data but
historically the best causal analyst
generally could not always obtain access
to good data
so i'm going to tell you since i've been
around for a long time what i'm going to
tell you is totally how it used to be in
the 1980s and much less now but not gone
away
and
this is in the context especially back
in the 1980s
if
no medical finding that had not been
verified in a um randomized clinical
trial was considered
by the medical profession to be valid
with maybe cigarette smoking and so
forth rare exceptions
so why was that well
uh here's how it used to go how common
it still is i don't know a specialist
academic doctor could capture a large
group of patients with a given disease
say
rheumatoid arthritis so you're a
rheumatoid arthritis specialist you're
famous you've written papers people come
to you
and you have this group of patients
under you okay that makes for a research
career because you get to publish
clinical paper papers often
observational based on these
patients and you never have to share the
data
um
these doctors who have these data are
not well
trained in designer analysis their only
relative advantage was possession of the
scarce resource the patient's charts
some would often rely on
non-cutting-edge analysts who were loyal
and willing to take subtle events to
make those p-values less than .05 as a
consequence the valuable data source was
used to publish often incorrect results
while withholding data from the analysts
that could correct them
the same doctors would then be vocal
advocates
of the point of view that only rcts and
not observational studies could be
trusted not recognizing that they
themselves were contributing to the lack
of trust
similarly in epidemiology investigators
who started large longitudinal cohorts
often would not share the data with
other analysts again interfering with
self-correcting requirements needed to
fit science
but these things are changing for many
reasons i'm going to focus on one the
emerging understanding of the kind of
things everyone here does the design and
causal analysis complex longitudinal
studies
requires a trained specialist
no less so than to say open heart
surgery require specialists current
examples my colleague miguel hernan was
asked to participate in the design
analysis of many observational studies
of covert during the pandemic including
the recent important studies of vaccine
efficacy using the israeli
health care system data which was the
best available
10 years ago a well-trained group of its
railway experts seeking the health of an
outsider
epidemiologist would have been much less
likely
and so
um
the very fact that
there's now understood the discipline of
causal inferences changing things
i won't go through because you all know
that
okay um
so what should be our goal well we'd
like to provide a quantitative degree of
confidence as to whether the analytic
results we obtain with whatever our
current state-of-the-art causal analysis
analysis methods are sufficiently
reliable to have a significant role in
decisions concerning medical public
health decisions
for example changing treatment
recommendations for regulating
environmental exposure
is that possible if so how
and before continuing i want to address
the misunderstanding that always arises
usually when you start talking about
this someone says you cannot establish
causality from a single study especially
observational rather meta-analyses must
be done or more importantly you need
different kinds of evidence brought to
bear triangulation including biological
studies animal studies biological
plausibility no one disagrees with any
of this but what i'm asking here is does
our analysis
of the epidemiologic observational data
or
randomized trial data
provide
independent evidence of sufficient
reliability to inform the process of
triangulating the causal
mechanism or the causal effect
and current ways that people are
supposed to do method
meta-analysis like the cockpit
collaboration are not really up to the
to the job they they go through a
checklist but they aren't very
um
they aren't very modern let's put it
that way
so to obtain a measure of confidence
we'd like to do some sort of meta
regression where we regress some measure
of the difference delta between our
observational estimates of a causal
effect
and the true causal effect on various
study cohere covariates including the
magnitude of the various constraints
limitations of the study being analyzed
that is various sources of bias and so
forth
and there are many problems with
implementing such an analysis basically
if we knew how
what were the factors that determine
whether we did well or poorly an
estimated causal effect with our
observational methods
on data set by data set study by study
we'd have someone a good understanding
of how we're performing so that would be
what we'd like unfortunately we don't
know the true causal effect which makes
that program vocal difficult
the best one can usually do is use the
results of a randomized trial
that's been performed as a surrogate for
the truth
so now the idea here is you is not that
um
is that
most
things that are studied
aren't studied by randomized trials it
would be too expensive it would be
logistical and
other
kinds of problems uh
in doing so
but
to know what so you have to use
observational methods but to do so
um
you would uh
um
to do so to be right you'd like to at
least get correct results on randomized
trials
that have been carried out to be sure
your observational methods applied to
observational data sets or agreeing with
the trials
so the question is how do we make
randomized trial surrogates as close as
possible to the true effect in our
observational study
well the basic idea is to emulate the
actual randomized trial using our
observational data not necessarily
usually on a different data set and we
emulate as closely as possible in terms
of eligibility
criteria how treatment and outcome are
defined and measured the length of
follow-up and so forth
now our observational study of course
may differ from the rct punctuation the
distribution of both measured and
unmeasured factors that rct populations
are um well known for being
cherry picked to
people most likely that drug companies
think will benefit so they can show
their drugs good
um
now measured factors there's you know a
whole
host of methods you know um
just different distributions of
covariance you can use likelihood ratios
and so forth to um
try to uh transport the results of your
trial to your observational study or
vice versa
so we can often adjust for those but the
unmeasured factors
are a real problem and notice that
remember that for
seeing whether effects are the same in
two treatment populations
the unmeasured factors don't have to be
confounders if you simply have a
different distribution
of an unmeasured factor u that causes y
that has nothing to do with treatment
you can get um you know at times you can
get different signs for the causal
effect depending on the kind of
interactions so it's in a certain sense
this is a
much more a much harder problem than um
confounding
um because you only
uh
transportability
so the only way to directly address the
difference in unmeasured covariance is
coordinate randomized trials uh with
observational studies as an example in
settings where the number of eligible
subjects for a randomized trial is
greater than the sample size required
for the trial are affordable one can
enter a random sample of the eligibles
in a
random sample of people eligible in the
for the trial
and conduct on
that group and a parallel observational
trial emulation
that is you split
the people eligible for trial two groups
when you do the trial the other you try
to emulate it with observational studies
and outside of such coordination which
is fairly rare
um
the best we can do is if we have
multiple rcts one will get a sense of
how close one could expect to get
um an rct benchmark
uh
to equal to be close to an rct we were
using as a benchmark by analyzing the
heterogeneity of the effects among the
trials themselves
or more viciously when you get
access to the trial data um you can try
to you know emulate each trial using the
other
um
and so forth anyway um
it's it was in the end this crew should
understand the factors that makes
successful emulation impossible as well
as possible for certain outcomes and
certain questions of covariance it does
it no matter what statistical method you
have
um you won't ever be guaranteed you've
uh that you can reproduce the causal
effect that can be intractable um
confounding
and uh the support but you have to know
when that's the case versus when it
isn't
and that's not so you can see that's not
only your statistical methods but you
need some empirical a large empirical
database having done these analyses and
some criteria with all the problems i've
just been describing
to know when you got it right and when
you got it wrong
okay
um
and um
as uh another
uh point is i've been
treating this as this randomized trials
or the gold standard but for millions of
reasons of course
they're not
um and you know they
don't do things under both real world
settings unless
um uh in most randomized trial where
they um
the people's the follow-up of people and
you know doses are monitored and so
forth are very different than
in um
uh real
what what would happen in the real world
if it wasn't within a trial and so you
know it's very hard to
compare the cause of effects you see in
that situation
to what you would see
um in an observational study where among
free living people are taking drugs or
not as they see um fit
and you know trials have limited
follow-up and a huge number of exclusion
criteria and so forth
um along the way you get many
interesting questions like if one's
hoping to use observational analyses and
decision making should the observational
analysis be pre-specified in the way
randomized trial analyses are are in the
protocol
myself i think
uh the answer should be is no
because um they're just um
too many factors to a priori
observational studies
um
uh be able to
say you are going to do precisely this
and then if you do it you are going to
not do things that will become pretty
clear during the course of the data
collection other things that you wish
you
had allowed yourself the right to do
so that means the way forward this more
algorithmic approach to what will be
done if various analytic problems arrive
what to do about those outliers without
missing exposure data et cetera and to
keep a record of every analysis to try
to keep people cherry-picking um that's
this is a whole other topic because
everyone knows um
and you know we i'll go on for that okay
so look for that
um oh this is it so
um
a major problem is to do the kind of
thing i'm talking about would take huge
resources and also
uh high-level researchers
who are dedicated to
trying to understand
how well
observational analyses which databases
can
return your causal results on uh which
substantive outcomes in what settings
and the problem is
this is not what people get tenure for
as everyone knows you know you get
tenure for developing new methods
analyzing novel studies with getting
interesting new findings and publishable
results and the whole program i've been
talking about is just the opposite
this is a major unsolved problem
in uh science i think
um
uh
forget that
um most of the methods that have been
developed just before have been methods
developed um
the assumption of sequential
ignorability i'm thinking of
longitudinal studies because that's
usually what most medical studies are
allowing for
unmeasured confounding just through
sensitivity analysis
uh recently
especially with
the
ml community entering the fray there are
now many methods
that claim to adjust for unmeasured
confounding under certain
conditions provably under usually under
mathematical rather than subject matter
assumptions i would say except for
proximal uh
inference of
mia wang and eric chechen chapman
started the field
um where they actually have um
epidemiologically meaningful assumptions
about what proxies would be the kind of
properties would be available if someone
could decide on subject matter grounds
uh you know other assumptions which may
be true and they do great we don't know
yet but are things more like you know
having to do with um
ranks of matrixes varsity and other
things and helped in fact the serious
confounders differ from
you know less important confounders in
various ways related to those facts
and so only
the kind of um
analyses i've been talking about
however allow us to tell which of these
um
assumptions um reflect the real world
which don't right now they're just
methods papers and the way i
think about it i think is to think about
all these new methods as black boxes
as they give you the data
outcomes the causal estimate
and we don't know which of the black
boxes if any is reliable it's sort of
like the history and ongoing history of
um
omics analysis where there's always been
big data many more experiments in
uh uh
order to magnitude more experiments that
could be done
and um
provided the methods are based on very
detailed excellent you know causal
theorizing summer uh
methods to say
you know
what is causal et cetera are based on
much less on rigorous causal thinking
but that doesn't a priori mean one's
going to do better than the other
because we don't really know enough to
know what's driving things
um
driving things it keeps this is much
more true i think of
um
observational data than
uh chronic disease then you know
homeless kind of data just
gets
less of it much more
complex and poorly measured all right um
okay
and then we'll all wait for the day when
everyone has randomized every patient
encounter which will be a good day
but that itself because there'll be so
much quotes non-clients afterwards
because
it'll just serve as many unconfounded
benchmarks um
all right
um
okay now i practically run out of time
right so the whole
um okay so that the other two all right
you're still okay you can still go yeah
you can
after 10 minutes
okay
so what are some of the methods
uh we've been using um a lot of them
um you know um
and
uh
i'm gonna describe some of the ways um
that we've been thinking
15 years
that um
are some of them that i don't think have
gotten into the literature very clearly
so first i'm going to have to talk about
throughout this about you know dynamic
regimes
where um treatments can be a x is gonna
be the covariance subscripts their time
over bars history so the dynamic regime
g is uh is a function of your data of
your covariates at time one x1
um
that tells uh tell g1 of x once it's the
treatment you're gonna take the time
one and so forth and finally at the last
time capital p
gt of x bar t over var is your whole
hist covariate of three a bar t minus
one is all that's treatment history and
that's the uh
g of t is going to be a function telling
you which treatment to take so there are
a lot of such regimes
okay and i'm going to use ht for the
past history um
and these okay let's go on so a target
trial so this is what we're doing with
observational data one way to think
about it it's
this way of describing it rather than
using counterfactuals so much is very
helpful in talking to physicians
um and other decision makers so a target
trial is a randomized trial one would
like to conduct on let's say hmo members
that cannot do that for various reasons
novel aspect of targeted trial emulation
what really has changed the way people
think about it
is that each subject in the
observational data is enrolled in all of
the target trials for which he is
eligible instead of a single trial
um so you get this big nesting so it's a
bit methodological advance although
you'll see in a sense it's not in
advance because it's really just a
structural nested model i'll get to that
in a moment
so we're going to consider so for
example i'm going to consider
uh
emulation of the effect of
postmenopausal
post-menopausal
hormone therapy on the
five-year deadlier risk of breast cancer
and post-menopausal women in the hmo
and who've not taken
uh
the criteria offended
trial they've not taken hormones for a
year
okay it'll be a time index okay so have
observational data
as shown over time on female members
um where xo's
pre-treatment data and we have a binary
every i'm going to make everything
binary it's treatment at time t dt is if
clinical breast cancer is diagnosed
better before t
um i start to use um
indicates whether you're eligible for
treatment this is a something if you
have had a deep vein thrombosis doctors
won't give you
um post-menopausal estrogens and your
eyes start to would be zero
it is whether um you're eligible for the
trial even if you could get treatment so
it0 even if a person hadn't had debate
thrombosis if um they had taken
post-menopausal
um hormones in the last year as
the criteria of the trial which you
shouldn't be able to do that
okay so let's consider a
concreteness
consider a woman who's trial eligible at
t
um the trial outcome is development of
clinical breast cancer within delta
years that's why t deltas
d t plus delta randomized with
probability uh have to on g star g prime
for their treatment regimes being
compared in the target trial that is
you're trying to use the observational
data to answer the question that would
be answered in the trial and describe
what we call
the target trial were emulated
okay so um
um
uh so
uh regimes might be
um so g star
there is the regime
given your past when you
up to t minus one you know entering the
trial
take
the one means take them
uh
first menopausal estrogens per year and
then never take them again
that's um that's corresponding to a
regime of one year of treatment which is
sometimes given um
and you might compare that to um
from one year eligible never taking
treatment one year versus never it would
be one contrast okay and we're going to
take as our um
uh
um
contrast by defined counterfactuals so
now i'm going to find counterfactors so
this the parentheses here says
counterfactual yeah so this is the
counter factual if you
when you
take your observed treatments with t
minus one
take uh
treatment for one year and then take no
more treatment after that given
st
are your past observed covariate some
covariates they're interested in and you
are eligible for the trial
minus
the counterfactual
where you never have once the trial
starts you never take treatment zero
rather than one so that's the kind of
thing we're trying to estimate
if it had been a true rct it would be
identified
just by taking the mean of the observed
outcome delta years after the trial
starts
um among people randomized the regime g
for d star
versus people randomized to the other
regime however of course the variable g
does not exist in the observational data
since there was no randomization at t
equal four when these are any other time
because all we have is observational
data that's what we're trying to emulate
that trial we don't have it so there's
no reason to privilege people for it
rather than any other value of p where
you might have started the study
that is for particular choices of
regimes g and g prime above the
observational data can be used to
emulate many trials
in fact any time
time t that you're eligible you can
be in a new trial you are a given person
can start many different
trials as long as she's eligible for
this hasn't had um postmenopausal
estrogens in the last year
um
okay
so now the question is okay
so if we're going to do that the
question then is how should we analyze
the trial i'm going to talk about how to
analyze it under you know unmeasured
confounders
okay that is uh you have sequential
ignorability or you can think of it
given your past history up to a given
time
the probability you get treated and the
observed data
is uh is random
that is it's by a point with probability
on the point possibly depending on your
entire past
um
so that there's no confounded
um
of course we don't know the point
probability that's
the propensity score so that's part of
the estimation problem
okay so
so if we're gonna um
if we're gonna uh do this analysis we
have to worry about whether
over parameterization incoherence you
might think it's gonna use a person over
and over
and that can be a problem and the fact
um the important part about these models
why they're useful is they're not
this is not a problem
you can never get a time you know a
contradiction if you use what are called
history-adjusted marginal structural
models you do get contradictions because
they're over parametrized and if you
want to ask more about this
in the discussion do so this is one of
the more interesting
things okay
so
how do i know how do i know
that
no matter
what rules you use
for these studies i'm going to be okay
okay so i'm going to define what's
called the
um
regime specific blip function so you've
given me a treatment regime
um
g and g bar t plus one this counter
factor means take your observed
treatment through t minus one
take treatment at t
and then follow the regime
you i'm talking giving you from t plus
one on that's a particular counter
factual for a given
regime and i'm going to contrast it with
the regime that only differs from that
in that um
in that you take zero with t and then
follow the regime
from there on
okay so people who do um
optimal treatment regimes this is very
familiar to you with this being the
optimal treatment for gene g
which is what you're trying to estimate
because that's how you find
depending on the sign of this you're
either treated at time t or
not given your um
given your past history
is determined by this contrast if this
is your optimal future
um
so now the important point is is if this
guy
is zero with probability one for all
times t less than
uh k i'm using j now for t plus delta
call it think of that again to follow up
it he's less than that
then under sequential randomization
um it for all regimes
gee
um
the counterfactual mean given the past
is just the expectation of the observed
y given the past with probability one
um so what this is saying is
um
uh this guy being zero
these
single blips being zero
are all the information
any regime g you give me
these blips um
are all the causal contrasts that could
ever be that are identifiable anything
else you estimate patches these together
um
you know it can be a weighted average of
them if these are all zero everything's
zero so given your past
one last blip of exposure eight t
equal one versus eight equals zero
before reverting to any given regime
if that's all zero for every t
for every t
and and the end of and if k let's just
make kb on the follow-up then there's
going to be um
there's going to be no causal effect in
the sense that nothing identifiable um
all identifiable um
causal contrast or zero that's all there
is
okay
um
and
but you get very different um
ways to analyze the data comparing
based on this and the reason is
is because of this
dynamic regime the different dynamic
regimes you can choose
so
um
again the one you all know about is
it
sorry so you turn the rap can you wrap
up in the next one okay we're running
out of time yeah
okay so um
the um
the
so the
the
the regime where i where um you take
zero thereafter
um that was a zero that regime is um the
one we were talking for take one
last clip of treatment before taking
zero thereafter on the other hand this
funny regime that says
um
uh what you should take at time t
is
the exact same treatment you took at
time t minus one you've i doubt you've
seen this machine before but this regime
is
the following it said it's comparing
always take treatment to never take
treatment no matter where you are
so let's say you're observed history
you've gone up and down in a given
moment
you've um
you um the last time you took treatment
then you're going to take
then the regime's asking you to take
treatment from that plank on forever so
it's like
whenever the whenever the quote study
starts you're going to take treatment
forever
um if you last time took one if you last
time took
zero you're never going to take it but
of course
this is the regimes i'm trying to
estimate
in fact some people in the data this is
definitely hard
will take but they're supposed to take
one according to this regime but they'll
take zero
and it's that it's because of that
you'll get you have observational
contrast to see
but in short this
weird regime is the one that always
gives a contrast of always take
treatment versus never take treatment
which is what's usually assigned in a
true randomized trial it's usually
always take treatment versus never and
this strange structural nested model
which you've probably not seen before
can reconstructs that
where a person is allowed to start
regimes as many times as they want the
um the actual contrast you'll get out of
these foot functions are contrast
between
at each time t i'm going to compare
people always took treatment to people
who never took treatment
um that's much too fast but um
i'll leave it at that and it's well
known how to estimate parameters
structural nested models so by knowing
the structural nested model knowing this
under sequential randomization
just telling you what g is is a complete
prescription of how to
analyze the data
for the particular contrast you're
interested in let's say you want to
always take treatment versus never
or you might take take it for one year
and then never those are those two
different g's i've shown here zero or
eight minus one and so that's a
prescription for
for doing the analysis under no
unmeasured values
um
i'll stop there since i ran out of time
all right great thank you so much for
the nice talk jamie
[Applause]
all right then we'll come to the panel
discussion i guess maybe you want us